scoffs is a marvelously rich poetic
language of the every day becoming
extraordinary we make words for what we
know and up here we know a lot about
weather especially snow there's a
well-known debate about whether or not a
Nuits have fifty words for snow
however it's less recognized that the
Scopes language has incredible 421 nor
related words and expressions
[Music]
I'm the great snow breaker who guards
the he'll haired shift Macan way again
elk Funes clumping through elk Odin left
my cheek stitched with Maggie's the
snail when's my breath my in burned
through the Fleniken the Brune the
hooves my grief in a blender Abrams
you'll see me snoop dune and maglin a
war Sheila and finit Saul it and thrown
as a fact I thought cron rookin snore
the minute it Sneezles I'm thinking or
fifa's and futures and sleet or snow
there in poker and devil I've a
dictionary of snore in my heat scores is
one of Scotland's three remaining
indigenous languages along with Gallic
in English it's a Germanic language but
it has many other influences and a
written tradition going back several
hundred years to when it was the
official language of the borough and
royal court it was and still is in some
rural parts of Scotland the language of
Agriculture fishing weather and
landscape nowadays is officially
recognized by Brussels and waste
minister as a minority or regional
language under European charter in the
2011 census and for one and a half
million scores identified a score
speakers
and the yen who brings his own words
through the Erlich and jetted Annette no
staufen first better our scale for smart
till Aseema he'll haired rekt and the
greets nor breaker for max the path for
the lambda yo the muckle top and the
woolly blue or the snows and the next
iran or winter who is neither blades nor
Naish the sherpa or the sheik world the
snow games made of flesh